a function f of x is plotted below
highlight an interval where f prime of x
where we could say the first derivative
of x uh the for the first derivative of
f
with respect to x is greater than zero
and f double prime of x or the second
derivative of f with respect to x is
less than zero so let's think about what
they're saying so we're looking for a
place where the first derivative is
greater than zero that means that the
slope of the tangent line is positive
that means that the function is
increasing over that interval so if we
just think about it here over this whole
region right over here the function is
clearly decreasing then the slope
becomes zero
right over here and then the function
starts increasing again all the way
until this point right over here it hits
zero and then it goes and the function
starts decreasing so we're gonna just
this first constraint right over here
tells us going to be something in this
interval right over there
and then they say where the second
derivative is less than zero
so this means that the the slope itself
whether it's whether it's positive or
negative that it's actually decreasing
we are going to be concave downwards
right over here the slope itself it
could be positive but it'll be coming
less and less and less positive and so
we're looking for a place where the
slope is positive but it's becoming less
and less and less positive
if you look in over right over here the
slope is positive but the slope is
increasing it's getting steeper and
steeper and steeper as we go and then
all of a sudden it starts getting less
deep less deep less deep less deep all
the way to when the slope gets back to
zero so if we want to select an interval
it would be this interval right over
here our slope is positive our function
is clearly increasing but it is
increasing at a lower and lower rate so
i will select that right over there
let's do one more example
a function f of x is plotted below
highlighted interval where f prime of x
is greater than zero so the same thing
where our function is increasing but
it's increasing at a slower and slower
rate so our function is increasing so
our function is increasing in this whole
region right over here and we see it's
really steep here then it's getting less
deep and less deep and it's getting
closer and closer to zero the slope of
the tangent line or the the rate of
increase of the function so i would pick
anything right around this region right
here